翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正: Kyoko Kamura
（演奏開始）
（拍手）
（演奏終了）
ありがとうございます
BimBomBam楽団です
俺は普通の家に生まれたんですね
音楽一家の家とかでなくて
お母さんとお父さんがすごく音楽好きで
子どもに音楽やらせて とか
めちゃめちゃ大金持ちの家に
生まれたわけじゃないんですね
普通に生まれたんですけども
子どもの頃からやってるトランペットを
こうして今も吹き続けられて —
いられる理由っていうのはですね
やっぱり人との出会いといいますか
縁とか繋がりとかのおかげだというふうに
俺は思ってて
今日はその辺の話をしたいなと思っています
ここのステージに
今立たせていただいているのも
縁があって立たせてもらってるんですけども
TEDxKobeのスタッフの方で —
このBimBomBam楽団の前に
「PE'Z」っていうバンドを
僕はやってまして
そのバンドのすごいファンだった方から
お誘いを受けて
このステージに立っているんですけども
その方が我々BimBomBamのライブに
遊びに来てくれて そして声をかけてくれて
それでやっとここに出られているから
行動が伴っているんですけども
やはり「出会い」という縁が
すごい力を発揮して
こういう風なところに登らせて
もらってるというところに
すごく感謝をしております
そもそも 僕がトランペットを
始めた理由というのも
すごく大きな出会いがあって
トランペットを始めたんですけども
幼少の頃 すごく病弱だったんですね
しょっちゅう風邪ひくというか
熱出したり 病院に運ばれたり
ご飯も全然食べられなかった
すごいひ弱な子どもだったんですけども
それを心配したうちの母親がですね
山とか 海とか 川とか
自然がいっぱいあるところに
しょっちゅう連れてってくれるように
なったんですね
少しでも自然に触れて 病弱な体質を
治そうとしてくれたんですけども
その中に斑尾高原という
場所がありまして
そこに行った時の話なんですけども
山の中とかで遊んでいると
ほんとにありえないくらい
でっかいオニヤンマが飛んできたり
すごいでっかいバッタがいて
ものすごい楽しく山の中で
遊んでいたんですね
すごく川とかも近くにあって
都会のど真ん中で生まれ育った俺としては
刺激的な場所なんですけども
そんな中で遊んでいると
遠くから音楽が聞こえてきまして
山の中からその音のする方に
ちょっと山を降りて近づいて行くとですね
なんとそこでフェスティバルを
やっていたんですね
せっかくなんで ということで
会場の外の 山の上の方で
遠くから眺めつつ 音楽を聴きつつ
休憩してたんですね
すると 会場の方から
１人の外国人が近寄ってまいりまして
山を駆け上ってきたんですけども
普通に考えたら「ヤバい 怒られる」
（笑）
多分うちの家族もそう思ったんですけど
そしたらその外国人が
「なんで中に入らないの？
なんで中で見ないの？
中で見た方が楽しいよ」
という風に言ってきたらしいんです
うちの母親は
「いやいや チケットもないし
ここでも充分だから楽しいですよ」
って答えたら
その方はですね
「じゃあいいよ ついておいで」と言って
我々家族を会場まで
連れて行ってくれたんですね
そこでバックパスを人数分くれて
会場の中へ招待してくれたんです
そこでライブというものを
初めて見ることになるんですけども
これがジャズフェスティバルだったんです
今はもう やっていないんですけども
「ニューポートジャズフェスティバル
イン 斑尾」というフェスティバルでした
その瞬間に 俺のこの「トランペットを吹く」
という人生が決まったんですね
その日から今日までずっと
トランペットを吹いています
（拍手）
このもういっこ後に拍手のタイミングが
あったんですけど
（笑）
その終わってしまったフェスティバルの
最後の年の時に
先ほど言いました このバンドの前に
やっていたPE'Zというバンドで
そのフェスティバルに
出演させていただきまして
やはり すごく人の繋がりは大事だと
俺の人生にすごくいい影響を与えたなって
いうふうに思っています
ここです
（拍手）
去年からBimBomBam楽団という
楽団をやっているんですけども
ジプシージャズという音楽を中心に
色んな国の音楽を取り入れて
オリジナルの曲を作って
みんなに聴いてもらってるんですけども
普段ライブやってる時はですね
お客さんに食事をしてもらったり
お酒を飲んでもらったりしながら
そういうところで
音楽も一緒に楽しんでもらう
その３つを全部楽しめる空間を作るという
コンセプトでこのバンドは活動してまして
「生活の一部に音楽を」という風に
テーマをつけてやってるんですね
そのバンドの始まりというのも
バイオリンのTajimiとですね
セッションでちらっと会ったのが
きっかけなんですけども
ジプシージャズの音楽を中心にした
バンドをやりたいなって思った時に
彼に 俺は声をかけまして
そしたら「すごいギタリストを
知ってるんで紹介します」って
このギターの手島さんを紹介してもらい
「もう一人 ベースも
すごいのがいるんです」と言って
すごいイケメンのベーシストを
紹介していただいて
で 俺の古くからの友達の
パーカッションの奥田と
こんな風に声かけて繋がって繋がって 今
奇跡的にこのバンドが結成されたんですけども
このバンドの始まりっていうのが
最年少のTajimi —
こう見えて最年少です
（笑）
で 最年長の俺と
最年少と最年長の出会いというのが
バンドの始まりというのも
なにかすごい面白いものを感じます
このバンドの活動の上で
この先にですね
そういう人の繋がりとかが
また影響してくると思うんですけども
出会いとかって その瞬間は
その先に自分の人生にどんな影響があるかとか
大きな影響 悪い影響があるかっていうのは
その時は全然感じていないことが
ほとんどだと思うんです
当たり前です
未来のことなんで
だけど こうやって思い返してみると
「あの出会いすごかったな」
「あの出会いのおかげで
今こうやってやれてるんだな」
ってことって 皆さんも
多分すごくいっぱいあると思うんです
なのでやはり
そういう風なことを感じた以上は
１回１回の出会い、繋がり
そういうのはやっぱり大事だなって
改めて思うように生きていきたいなって
いう風に 今は感じています
今日もこういう風に この場所で演奏して
しゃべらせてもらってますけども
多分 ほとんどの方が
初めましてだと思うんですね
これもやっぱり
すごい大きな縁だと思うんです
この先に皆さんの人生にとって
俺らの人生にとって
今日のこの場は すごい影響を
与えるっていう場だと信じてですね
今日は最後まで 思いきって演奏したいなと
思ってるんですけども
長々としゃべらせてもらいましたけども
我々は音楽家ですので
しゃべりでは
全て伝えることはできません
なので もう１曲だけ
最後に聞いてもらいたいと思います
（拍手）
『ユキミチヲユケバ』を聴いてください
（演奏開始）
（演奏終了）
（拍手）